there is never a bad time to open a  great business and there is never a good  time to open a shitty business yes we're  heading into a recession potentially but  if you're a great operator wine library  when i took over recession exploded it  me and aj started vaynermedia recession  at micro recession exploded it if you're  a good enough operator it's always a  good time to open a business if you're  passionate and understand what to do and  if you're not a good operator we could  be in frothy frothy land like we were  the last decade and you will lose i  watched tons of businesses go out of  business five years ago when it was easy  as [ __ ]